[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Your first
project holds the promise
of the new technology
you're introducing
to your organization.
If selected and
executed well, it
can be a showcase
that makes it easier
to achieve repeated success with
subsequent programs of work.
Every business is competing
in a digital landscape,
irrespective of the industry.
In our modern digital
age, speed is key.
Speed gives the ability to
respond to business challenges
and opportunities
with digital solutions
quickly, and at scale.
Your ability to quickly build
and manage APIs with Apigee
is a key tool for success.
Your first delivery needs
to demonstrate and validate
to your organization
your ability
to deliver at speed something
that matters to the company.
We call this delivery the
minimum viable business
outcome.
Your MVBO is an early
win that delivers
APIs that are core
to your business,
and creates early momentum with
a pathway for repeated success.
Drawing from many years
of working with enterprise
customers to help them with
delivering on their API
programs, we've seen
patterns that typically
lead to increased
risk of failure
or the transformation
program stalling out.
Let's take a look.
Typical adoption patterns look
like an S curve, as shown here.
The first part of
the curve is assured.
And after all, you have
the budget and the team
to get the first
delivery completed.
However, subsequent
adoption can be harder,
and is often predicated
on the success
of the early deliveries.
In our experience, customers
who get into production
quickly with something
core to their business
are able to maintain and
build stronger momentum
on the platform,
and are much more
successful at achieving their
goals of speed and agility
over the long term.
Careful selection of
your first project
will help you achieve this.
We'd like to offer three
essential components that
will improve your
chances for success.
We think about these
three characteristics
for selecting your
first project--
ready, rewarding, and relevant.
Let's explore these
characteristics in more detail.
Completing your first
delivery quickly
with something core
to your business
gives your program
its strongest start.
Ready means selecting
an MVBO that
allows for that quick delivery.
This means ideally
avoiding items
that may require significant
backend refactoring that
might take many
months to complete,
or avoiding the items
that have dependencies
on other programs
of work that'll
take also months to complete.
For example, an API
for a mobile app
refresh planned
months in the future.
Rewarding means ensuring your
MVBO is a strong showcase
and demonstrates value
to the organization.
Ideally, value here
means recognizable value
to your business leadership that
is a real and tangible impact
to your bottom line.
You may be enabling a new
line of revenue or increasing
engagement with customers.
The best examples are
measurable with respect
to the end user
of your business.
For example, for retail, this
might be measured in sales.
For insurance, it might be
measured in handling time
for new claims processing.
A great example will also
provide bragging rights
for your sponsor.
You might want to
deliver something
that allows your leadership
to widely share the success
to help bring attention
to the new capability that
was delivered quickly.
Relevant means that the
initial MVBO is a good use
case for API management.
This could be reducing
friction for developer adoption
through better self
service developer portals,
or measuring usage
through analytics
that allow traffic to be tied
back to the business drivers.
Starting by selecting an MVBO
that is ready, rewarding,
and relevant will provide
for the strongest start
in a way that sets
your program up
for sustained momentum
and long term success.
I'd like to share a couple of
real world customer stories
that show how starting with a
good MVBO led to that success
long term.
The first is a multinational
bank operating out
of the Middle East, wanting to
demonstrate the ability to get
new products to market quickly.
Furthermore, their
leadership were looking
to showcase product innovation.
The project team responsible
for deploying Apigee
decided to start with a handful
of pretty straightforward APIs.
One was an identity API to
track user authorization,
an account API with the ability
to set savings interest rates,
and a wrapper for
the Apple Watch API
that could pull step
count information.
The team was able to launch
a new savings account that
linked to your Apple Watch such
that the further you walked,
the higher your interest rate.
Pretty nice, huh?
Importantly, they were able
to launch this new product
in just 12 weeks, way
faster than the typical time
frames for product
development for this bank.
That's even better.
Our second example
comes from retail.
This well-established
brick and mortar retailer
was looking to defend against
online only new market entrants
by successfully launching
their own e-commerce store.
Instead of trying to do
too much at the start,
they began with
simple use cases that
were core to enabling
the e-commerce business,
including inventory and
customer information.
After securing
success and confidence
by delivering on
these early use cases,
they found other
business leaders
in the organization
coming to the API team
to create an access
similar tools.
Over time, this
led to a buildout
of a full set of capabilities
towards establishing
a federated ecosystem where
distributed sellers could
do business with customers
via the API powered
e-commerce platform.
Best of luck with
your first project.
If you want more
information, please check out
the community for
ebooks, articles,
and other related topics.
Thank you for watching.